[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les petits enfants ce soir nous
sommes venus vous voir parce que vous
faites tous très bien votre toilette
n'est ce pas nounours ah ça oui patron
et puis c'est amusant de faire sa
toilette
moi j'adore faire ma toilette et dont
l'échelle je descends voir mes deux
petits habille les mes petits neveux
chéri poto poto poto
kate ou encore une cuillère thomas
aufort les enfants ont soif élevé au
sein annonce qui vient jouer avec nous
oui oui bien sûr je vais en eau soit
gentil toutou pour faire plaisir à tous
autant aux eaux mais on parle de moi à
plat voyons voir ce qui se passe dit ne
rien faire ce que je n'y vais pas mâché
ses mots c'est pas possible ça moi je la
mange toujours à sous ont pas reste que
cette auto face à l ennemi ou et et rsa
ils ont bien mangé leurs sous et
maintenant les jours avec mikko n'a pas
tu le manges deux cuillères et tu vas
faire joujou comme ça à toi
cole thomas
ce que le bon sens où c'est la bonne
soupe à tout haut
c'est vrai ça fait autant de tanger fès
et voilà mon chéri bas la bonne sous le
pied dans le nord où la mamelle fuller
toute neuve dakar pas trop je les couche
et j'arrive
c'est bien mon petit toto tu vas te
coucher sans vendu à l'eau ou le dos aux
vitesses en avant
oh
où
on
ollon les oursons oui on va se coucher
tout seul l'os du grand auch a pu enfin
les mamans mais sa mort si bon soir les
enfants sages
là je vous porte au nez des chérubins
alors voilà je sais ce qu'il me reste à
faire
je le sud
bon
[Musique]
oh
où
[Musique]
je me demande ce que va faire notre
pauvre nounours patron ce très important
j'ai un grand service à vous demander
quoi dans mon gros nounours vous ne
pourriez pas chanter votre belle chanson
pour endormir mes petits neveux mais
bien c'est en et orci
je suis le marchand de stable la journée
un mini il faut être raisonnable
[Musique]
c'est le moment d'aller au lit tous les
jours sur mon nuage
[Musique]
nous nous revient avec moi et nous
partons en voyage dans le ciel par
dessus les toits
nous
je n'ai pas d'autre bagages qu'un niveau
enchanté et du haut de mon nuage je
serai memon stable doré
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants du monde
à demain
nuit moi je continue ma ronde
bonne nuit à tous les petits bonheurs
nuit à tous les petits
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]